[Music]
the release of the molar report last
week questions are rightly being asked
about what comes next congressman Doug
Collins tweeted this quote claims Muller
report punts the special councils work
to Congress is just wrong the report
analyzes Congress's constitutional
authority to legislate it does not
append the separation of powers by
calling Congress to continue a completed
DOJ investigation joining us now in his
first interview by the way since the
Moller report came out he was out of the
country Senate Judiciary Committee
chairman Lindsey Graham well you know we
kind of needed you last week and there
you are I don't know where the hell we
could have used to shoot your thoughts
and reaction more importantly what
you're going to do okay well number one
the idea that the Muller report is not
the final word on all things Trump
Russia collusion and obstruction is news
to me I thought we all trusted Muller so
here's what I think in the it's going on
in the house there's going to be a
stampede impeach President Trump they're
gonna use the mobile report anything
they can find to try to destroy his
presidency Nancy Pelosi is not in charge
of the Democratic Party the radical left
is in charge so I expect that they will
be impeachment proceedings against
President Trump in the Moller report to
me is vindication of President Trump
well you said it's over I agree with you
you said a stampede it is over for me
let me tell you I I think now we've had
four we have had nine month
investigation by the FBI even struck an
page that there's no there there did we
had nothing page said then we had the
house Intel committee investigation then
the bipartisan Senate committee now the
Moller report you can't say it any more
clearly no collusion so now the American
people the answer is in on this if they
want to do this on top of the Green Deal
what are the political ramifications for
not serving the American people well I
think they'll get punished in 2020 and I
think President Trump will get reelected
I know what happened in 98 when the
American people understood what they got
with Bill Clinton they understand
President Trump
warts and all and Mahler was the guy
that I was going to let
look at make sure he looked at the idea
of Trump working with the Russians the
verdict is in there was no collusion
there's no obstruction of a crime it
never occurred the obstruction thing was
bizarre to me to begin with so here's
what I think they're going to be
stampeded to impeach Trump because they
hate him so much and I hate it for the
country I hate it for the president but
it's going to result in him getting
reelected the media is not covering the
trump presidency they're trying to
destroy it the Democratic Party doesn't
accept the fact that President Trump won
so at the end of the day we're just
going to have to deal with this in 2020
at the ballot box so there were three
big components here that have not been
resolved we now know the investigation
into Hillary was rigged
even as a motive rattle Lynch was
running every decision a matter not an
investigation then we have the attempt
to use a phony Russian deceive in the
New York Times admitting tonight which
is interesting Washington Post writing
Oh Fox News was right
especially Hannity whatever but more
importantly thought about who's right
but a rigged investigation and attempt
to rig a presidential election and then
undo and unseat a duly like the
president what will you do specifically
well there's before and after the
campaign before the campaign I want to
find out did George papadopolis was he
working with the Russians or did they
plant in his mind that the Russians had
Hillary Clinton's email in other words
did the knowledge about Russian the
Clinton emails come from somebody other
than Russia how could you use the
dossier for different times to get a
warrant against American citizen when
it's a bunch of garbage why didn't they
tell the court that it was a politically
motivated document I'm gonna try to find
out about the counterintelligence
investigation about how the FISA warrant
was obtained against Carter Paige was
there an effort to invoke the 25th
amendment who's telling the truth McCabe
a Rosenstein the person who leaked to
The Washington Post that general Flynn
was being surveilled during the
transition period if you can find out
that person that's probably the one who
started all this
and it might be long it might be a lot
earlier than the date we were told which
is July 31st and they outsource that our
intelligence community outsourced
illegal activities to our allies to
bypass American laws Intel abuse turned
on American citizens unmasking leaking a
lot to get to here lying to Congress all
right senator good to see you welcome
back by the way